[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
if you'd like to help me produce more
content like this and get early access
to every new video consider becoming a
patron at patreon.com
second thought how many dramatic news
stories have you seen about the world
running out of food
how many times have you heard someone
justify horrible ideas based on the
notion that there's simply not enough to
go around
the world is a big place and we have a
lot of mouths to feed but the problem
may not be what you think it is
in this episode we're going to examine
whether the earth is actually short on
food
and look at the broader trends in food
production and consumption around the
world
let's rewind a bit it took thousands of
years for the human population to reach
the roughly 7.8 billion individuals we
have today
from the very first homo sapiens around
200 000 years ago up until 1804
there were fewer than 1 billion humans
on earth then in just 123 years the
population doubled to 2 billion
more recently it only took 12 years for
the latest billion humans to appear
our incredible technological advances in
medicine education and food production
since the industrial revolution have
improved our survival chances and
provided enough food for billions more
mouths than ever before possible
while this is cause for celebration and
admiration of homo sapiens achievements
it also raises an important question how
long is this trend going to continue
food insecurity is becoming a growing
concern all the way back in 1798 the
economist robert malthus realized that
in a world of limited resources
exponential growth cannot be sustained
indefinitely and will eventually lead to
a dramatic collapse
once the growing species overshoots the
ability of its support system to provide
it with resources
of course anytime malthus is mentioned
we also need to add the disclaimer that
there's a reason the term malthusian is
used as an insult
the views espoused by robert malthus
have been claimed in more recent years
by some of the most repugnant groups
imaginable
these groups use the economist theories
to justify eugenics and racial bigotry
to an extreme degree
but regardless of this vocal minority we
still need to consider these questions
have we already reached this limit are
we getting close to it
the number of malnourished people around
the world is still shockingly high
and millions die from hunger every year
in a world where obesity is the leading
cause of death from heart disease and
cancer
the top killers in the u.s how is it
that we still have more than 9 million
people dying from hunger every year
to put that number in perspective every
year hunger kills more people than aids
malaria and tuberculosis combined
it kills more people than the total
population of the world's 72 smallest
countries
and most of its victims 5.3 million of
them
are children but food insecurity does
not limit itself to the number of people
dying from hunger
it also includes the millions of people
who lack access to quality nutritious
foods on a daily basis
while most people in western countries
can generally rely on the availability
of food in supermarkets
many around the world are not so lucky
in war-torn syria
a country which we should note suffers
under the boot of monstrous u.s
sanctions
women have to stand in line for up to
seven hours for their allotted quota of
bread at this very moment
to make matters worse human-induced
climate change threatens our existing
food supplies as fresh water begins to
run out in many hotter regions
the rise in temperatures also allows new
pests to survive
in regions that were previously too cool
wiping out entire years worth of crops
and causing famines in some regions of
the world
yet another factor adding to food
insecurity is the ever-rising cost of
producing food
farmers at the bottom of the food
production process earn little to
nothing for their goods
and many are forced to buy seasonal
seeds from multinational corporations
meaning that every year they need to buy
more or fail to produce their crops
food production is now part of a global
system designed to generate capital not
ensure food security
so why are all these problems worsening
to the extent that they threaten that
most basic necessity of life
the most vocal claim that population
growth is the real problem
too many mouths to feed and too little
food to go around the malthusian theory
of exponential growth
while this theory is likely correct for
any system with limited resources
it did not take into account more modern
methods of production and it would only
become a problem for us once we
exhausted our tremendous supply of
resources but is our current problem
really one of population overshooting
resources
or is it more insidious is food
insecurity just an inevitable
consequence of humanity's growth
or could it be due to other factors
maybe our running out of food is not due
to the number of people we need to feed
but to a system that is failing to do
its supposed job
here are a few facts that should make it
obvious there is something going
terribly wrong with our global food
system
one-third of all food produced globally
goes to waste 1.3 billion tons
or one trillion dollars of food are
wasted every year
and just one quarter of the food wasted
by the eu
uk and u.s could feed all the world's
hungry
there are many other statistics like
this but all of them point to one simple
fact
there is more than enough food for
everyone but our food system guarantees
that some will go hungry
we do not currently have a problem of
supply and demand
we have a problem of production and
distribution food insecurity is not a
natural result of population growth but
a man-made crisis caused by a failing
inhumane system
as with many basic human necessities
under a capitalist system
food is a commodity to be traded in
order to make a profit
the more food we produce and sell the
more money there is to be made
so under the guise of tackling food
security to provide for all
we have developed intensive farming
methods to produce ever greater
quantities at ever lower prices
this race to the bottom in food prices
has come at tremendous cost
both in terms of food quality and
environmental damage
we have built ever more efficient
methods of trawling the seas
more efficient ways of jamming livestock
into small spaces
and more efficient ways of producing
more crops on less land
for decades the environmental cost of
these practices was ignored and any way
to improve yield was seen as a good way
forward
today we are finally realizing the price
we're about to pay for such reckless
intensification of food production
fish is the number one source of protein
in the world yet eighty percent of the
world's fish stocks are overfished and
on the brink of collapse
super trawlers continue to destroy
seabeds and pull out hundreds of tons of
fish every year
regardless of size age or species the
trawling done in the north sea alone is
equivalent to bulldozing the amazon
rainforest seven
times a year at the current rate of
destruction the world will run out of
seafood in 2048
at which point food insecurity will
affect billions across the planet
the impact of agriculture on the world's
ecosystems by far eclipses the damage
done by any other industry
as we continue to wrestle with a
worldwide pandemic we may want to pause
and think about how the meat and dairy
industries have been contributing to the
development of super pathogens for
several decades
in the u.s eighty percent of all
antibiotics produced by pharmaceutical
companies are sold to be used on animals
the appalling conditions factory animals
live in forced them into such close and
constant contact that the only way to
avoid disease outbreaks is to pump them
full of antibiotics
we know that overuse of these drugs is
the most likely factor to lead to
antibiotic resistant diseases
some of which may evolve to become
unstoppable when this happens
the impact on the human food supply will
be devastating
it isn't just antibiotics though raising
animals to be used as food
produces more greenhouse gas emissions
than the entire transportation sector
this is made worse by the
ever-increasing deforestation of vast
parts of the amazon and other
rainforests
which in turn releases more carbon from
cutting trees destroying forests to
raise cattle or grow single crops causes
the loss of essential biodiversity and
leaves our food supply vulnerable to
disease
and climate change as single species do
not have the resilience of whole
ecosystems
finally manure and waste from intensive
animal agriculture cause eutrophication
the death of lakes and rivers covered by
algal blooms and ocean dead zones
turning freshwater toxic and killing
millions of aquatic animals
all this to produce a food that consumes
billions of gallons of water
countless acres of land and tons of
crops that could otherwise be used for
humans
converting crops into meat is the most
inefficient way of using the food we
grow and is directly responsible for
worsening the climate and food crises
we've caused
the environmental damage goes on but the
purpose of this video is not to discuss
the negative effects of modern
agriculture
but rather to point out how relying on
this system to produce our food will
inevitably lead to a climatic collapse
which will destroy our food supply and
leave billions to starve
so why do we keep going why don't we
stop this obviously ridiculous spiral
into irreparable damage
the answer is simple there is more
immediate profit to be made from
continuing as we are
than by fixing the system there is
currently no political interest in
overhauling our food system and
transitioning to new methods that can
ensure food security for all humans
and the continued livability of our
planet in fact
the exact opposite is true political
will currently uses taxpayer money to
incentivize and subsidize industries
that at this rate
have no future both economically and
environmentally
the modern meat dairy and fishing
industries make absolutely no sense
the cost of fish meat or milk in
supermarkets and restaurants is
unbelievably low
especially when compared to fresh greens
despite the availability of fish having
collapsed worldwide and the production
of beef being vastly more resource
intensive than vegetables
this phenomenon makes no sense
economically nor ecologically
and it threatens food security worldwide
it would take a whole episode of its own
to cover this topic sufficiently
but it's enough to say that the only
things keeping this absurdity going are
the lobbying and financial interests of
the meat dairy and pharmaceutical
lobbies as well as the political fear of
causing more job losses in a dying
industry
there are very real solutions to
tackling food insecurity
solutions that have been obvious for a
long time and just require some
financing and political will to
implement
ensuring there is enough food for
everyone today and in the future is a
matter of organization and
prioritization
not population control the death of the
oceans and the exhaustion of our soils
is inevitable if we continue with
business as usual
but a more positive alternative is also
possible a world where all human beings
have enough to eat without the
degradation and depletion of the
planet's natural resources
however to get there we need a complete
overhaul of our food system as it exists
today
we need to fundamentally shift from
producing food for its economic value
to producing food with the sole purpose
of making sure no one goes hungry
we don't need to change everything
overnight either these essential changes
could be implemented over a transition
period empowering our current farmers
and fishers to help in the struggle
against climate catastrophe and food
insecurity
with the right political and financial
backing we could transform the food
system as we know
it first we need to redistribute our
current food supply to solve the ongoing
hunger crisis
second we need to subsidize regenerative
farming techniques
ban the use of destructive methods and
end subsidies for foods that harm
societal and planetary health
we already understand plant biology
enough to design permaculture farms that
yield far more food per unit area than
intensive farms while repairing our
soils
this would also make healthy foods
affordable to the average citizen
boosting overall health what's more new
technology is making vertical farms and
self-sustaining cities possible
finally we need to continue expanding
work in nutrition science that reveals
exactly what foods are good for the
human body so we can focus on providing
the world's population with quality
nutritious food instead of the
mass-produced poison offered by
multinational food conglomerates
the bottom line is this our food system
is failing both the well-fed and the
hungry
and will inevitably lead to a terrible
global famine to end this cycle of
self-destruction
we must transform the way we see food
and transform the kinds of food we
produce
and the way we produce it for everyone's
sake
[Music]
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is made
possible by my patrons on patreon
this kind of video while very important
is something that sponsors won't touch
in order to pay the bills and keep this
channel running i rely on adsense
revenue sponsors and donations from
generous viewers
by producing content like this i lose
out on both sponsors and adsense
if you enjoy the kind of videos i'm
producing and you're able to chip in
even a dollar a month i would greatly
appreciate the support
you can find my patreon page join our
growing discord server
and get early access to every episode at
patreon.com
second thought if you enjoyed this video
consider dropping a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you